this is the leading cause of preventable
death The Who estimates tobacco kills
more than 8 million people each year
including those exposed to secondhand
smoke support for the anti-smoking
movement is growing many governments are
working to reduce the number of smokers
including New Zealand where the number
of people who smoke has fallen to
6.8% the country was the first to pass a
ban a year ago this is now being
reversed under the new Administration
much to the disappointment of
anti-smoking Advocates I think it's
important to recognize that politicians
come and go but the polling that we've
done shows that
denization reducing the availability of
tobacco products and the smokefree
generation they're based on very strong
evidence and they're very popular and
that evidence is never going to go away
Malaysia 2 had a plan to curb smoking
but those Provisions were ultimately
dropped from proposed legislation Public
Health experts say the opposition to
such a ban is misguided it's felt that
it is a ban on existing smokers and uh
Vape users and therefore uh it is
something of a a deprivation of of
Liberty right there uh and that's where
most of the objection lies but the fact
of the matter is it's actually trying to
protect our children our grandchildren
and those who come after us from being
addicted to nicotine to begin with
anti-smoking Advocates find themselves
going up against a powerful opponent the
tobacco industry that's estimated to be
worth $1 trillion by
2030 the British government has said it
plans to introduce a new law that would
prohibit cigarette sales in England to
individuals born after January 1st 2009
it's highly likely that the tobacco
industry would look to do things like
judicial review legal challenges um
that's part of their playbook in the UK
and around the world to try and chill uh
the regulatory process and slow it down
um but I I I know that our government
has previously stood up to the tobacco
industry and I'm sure that they will
stand up to them again England could end
up being the first to impose a
generational ban on cigarette sales
Florence Louie Al jazer